Principal components.
So, fundamentally, principal
components are about the directions.
The component is really a direction in
a featured space along which the points
that you care about in that space have
the greatest variation or variants.
We'll make all of this more formal,
in a minute.
So, the first, it says PC here,
first principal component,
is the direction of maximum variance.
Now a quick word of warning.
You see here, I've got this little
symbol here that indicates that's where
the mean of the points is.
Principal components is mathematically
defined about the origin.
So what we typically do is we talk
about moving all of the points
to have their mean at the origin.
But then we forget that it's doing that,
we have to do it in the math and
we would draw something like this and
say you see this?
This direction, that's the first
principle component of those points.
It's the direction of maximum variance.
They're not around the origin here so
we have to shift it actually
before we do the computation but
when we think about it we're only
talking about with respect to the mean,
and the subsequent principle components
are perpendicular or orthogonal to
the previous ones, and describe
a next greatest amount of variance.
Now, in two dimensions,
we're sort of done, right?
So, we say, well, that's the first one.
Well, the next one's gotta be there,
because there's only two dimensions so
it's gotta go to that direction.
But if I was in three dimensions,
I would have my first dimension and
then everything would be along there, so
I could remove that, collapse it down on
a plane, let's say in that plane, what's
the maximum variation that will be my
second one, and then I would have
the third one that will be left.